es momento de nuestra revista de prensa
con Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Hola Ángela Buenos días Pues vamos a
entrar en materia ya es viernes y
tenemos que sacar el mayor provecho los
medios del país del cono sur de
Argentina posicionaron claramente sus
posturas a favor y en contra del acto
que fue protagonizado ayer por Cristina
Fernández en honor a los 20 años del
kirchnerismo si le parece vamos a
comenzar hablando de ello y del medio
del clarín si Ángela vamos a empezar con
Clarín un medio no muy afín a Cristina
Fernández por su línea editorial que
habla de ese despliegue de medios y de
fuerza del kirchnerismo ayer en Buenos
Aires en la clásica Plaza de Mayo cuando
se cumplían eso no 20 años de el ascenso
de Néstor kirchner al poder Cristina
Fernández de kirchner se vio ayer
rodeada de sus familiares de una turba
de pues afiliados al kirchnerismo y
también de Sergio mas el ministro de
economía que llegó a sonar como
presidenciable para las elecciones de
final de año el acto empezó con media
hora de adelanto y dice Clarín una
puntualidad cristinista que es una
rareza por temor a que las miles de
personas que se agolpaban en la Plaza de
Mayo se fueran por la intensa lluvia que
caía ayer en Buenos Aires Cristina
Fernández dice clarina aprovechó la
ocasión para victimizarse una vez más
llamó a la Corte Suprema mamarracho
indigno Y ella dice que es víctima de
una persecución política de más Clarín
refleja que durante el acto las miles de
personas que se ha agolpaban ayer en la
Plaza de Mayo coreaban incesantemente
una más y no jodemos más En referencia a
que Cristina Fernández se replantee su
no deseo de presentarse a las elecciones
de finales de año Bueno un invitado o
más bien una persona que no estuvo
invitada y esto también sonó en todos
los titulares no el presidente por ahí
no no página 12 también lo reseña si
Ángela ahí con un tono mucho más amable
con Cristina Fernández hemos destacado
un artículo de opinión de Luis brusten
que dice que ayer el acto en Buenos
Aires da muestra de la vigencia de un
liderazgo que potencia la autoridad de
Cristina Fernández y que la
vicepresidenta marcó su discurso en
cuatro ejes el primero llegará a un
acuerdo con el fmi para potenciar el
crecimiento económico de Argentina el
segundo Buscar una cooperación público
privada en el sector también económico
el tercero lograr un acuerdo para
renovar el pacto democrático y el cuarto
renovar también lo que ella dice es un
sistema judicial anacrónico Cristina
Fernández ayer no presentó a un
candidato lo que dice página 12 es una
Clara decisión política y también lo que
quedó claro textualmente es quién tendrá
un papel protagónico en esos en esos
nombramientos O sea ella misma
como ha sido siempre alrededor de la
figura del kirchnerismo y la nación
Marta la nación Angela también muy
crítica con Cristina Fernández hemos
destacado otro artículo de opinión Que
firma en este caso Claudio Jacqueline
que dice que lo que ocurrió ayer en
Buenos Aires no es más que una
conmemoración auto celebratoria sin
anuncios ni despedida ni siquiera un
plan de acción definido y preciso como
si no hubiera urgencias dice este
artículo de opinión dice este artículo
también que el discurso estuvo lleno de
tópicos con críticas habituales al
sistema judicial ya los medios
hegemónicos y que fue textualmente
también un espejo retrovisor y un himno
a la utopía retrospectiva con un intento
refundacional como vemos polarización en
los medios argentinos a puertas de las
elecciones elecciones que Marta a
propósito France 24 va a estar cubriendo
de primera mano y con enviados Bueno
vamos a cambiar radicalmente de tema Las
puertas de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones turcas este domingo están ya
abiertas al yasira ha hecho el día de
hoy un repaso y un comparativo sobre las
principales propuestas de los dos
candidatos en temas que son claves Y
controversiales aunque valga decirlo
Marta a estas alturas la gente ya tiene
decidido su voto por supuesto Ángela
quedan 48 horas y la contienda entre
Roger y que ya está casi definida lo que
hace al jazzira hoy es poner un poco en
comparativa esos puntos clave de las
propuestas electorales de ambos
candidatos por ejemplo en materia de
seguridad erdogana propuesto con un
discurso muy nacionalista aplastar a lo
que él dice las formaciones terroristas
como los partidos del kurdistán ha dicho
que quiere devolver a más de un millón
de sirios a su tierra natal Pero eso sí
liderando e implementando proyectos de
vivienda en la Siria controlada por
Turquía ha dicho que se compromete
también a mantener en Las bajas tasas de
interés pese a la hiperin que reina en
Turquía y para Los afectados del
terremoto de febrero ha dicho que se
compromete a dar préstamos hipotecarios
con un vencimiento de 20 años con dos
años de Gracia por su parte que malt
cliché el candidato de la oposición ha
prometido también combatir el terrorismo
Eso sí sin referencia explícita a los
partidos kurdos también ha dicho Y con
ansia de atraer el voto
ultranacionalista ella ha redoblado esos
discursos contra los refugiados también
ha dicho que quiere revertir las
políticas económicas de erdoan y
favorecer o atraer la inversión
extranjera y para Los afectados del
terremoto según kilisaroglu quiere dar
viviendas gratuitas para todos aquellos
que sufrieron las consecuencias de los
sismos en Febrero Pues Marta sobre este
tema espero podamos ahondar con nuestra
primera invitada del día porque ya
France 24 está haciendo sus respectivas
previsiones para este domingo vamos a
terminar con un homenaje que hacen
varios medios estadounidenses a Henry
kissinger que mañana nada más y nada
menos que 100 años y además usted
también está de celebración comparten
cumpleaños mañana mañana será para mi
cumpleaños pero cumplo unos pocos menos
que gente kissinger pero bueno Angel
hemos destacado como primera opción un
artículo de opinión del Washington post
que redacta su propio hijo de David
kissinger y que dice que un poco Cuáles
son las claves de la longevidad de su
padre primero hace una nota cómica y
dice textualmente la longevidad de Mi
padre es especialmente milagrosa si se
tiene en cuenta el régimen de salud que
ha seguido a lo largo de su vida adulta
que incluye una dieta rica en salchichas
alemanas y escalopes vieneses una toma
de decisiones implacablemente estresante
y un amor por los deportes únicamente
como espectador nunca como participante
pero ya pues saliendo de esta nota
cómica dice que los ingredientes de Pues
que gente kissinger cumpla mañana 100
años son su Insaciable curiosidad que lo
mantiene comprometido con el mundo y por
otra parte su sentido de Misión su
compromiso con la diplomacia y los
valores de la vieja política
Pues bueno Marta así damos por cerrada
la revista de prensa por esta semana
Aunque pues también quisiera antes antes
de este cierre que hiciéramos una rápida
revisión por último medio Sí vamos con
la revista Time Ángela que titula
también en un artículo lecciones de
Henry kissinger para el mundo de hoy
valores como la experiencia global o la
sensibilidad cultural son valores
adquiridos y atemporales y únicos y que
no están presentes entre los mandatarios
de la política exterior actual
estadounidense que se pasan dice este
artículo más tiempo tuiteando que
aprendiendo idiomas también dice este
artículo del time por cerrar que las
negociaciones con China o Rusia no pasan
por el apaciguamiento sino por la
inclusión de poderes y el ajuste a sus
intereses y que todos esos valores los
Encarna Henry Singer y los tendría que
trasladar a los mandatarios actuales en
Estados Unidos Bueno pues ahora sí Marta
Muchísimas gracias a usted Le deseo que
tenga un feliz fin de semana un feliz
cumpleaños y la próxima semana aquí nos
vemos Muchas gracias Ángela